I always thought I had a good cartoony
voice and it was kind of a dream of mine
to be able to do an animated film this
is like the nicest hotel I've ever been
to
yeah I'm horrible at memorizing lines so
it's really nice to be able to just read
them
Chrissy makes her animated movie debut
is the Invisible Woman in this third
installment of the monster movie Adam
Sandler is back as Dracula Selena Gomez
returns as his daughter I love the
feeling of making people laugh because
there's not a better feeling in the
world oh my gosh this is gonna be so
much fun it's such a fun-filled diverse
family and we're always getting into
some sort of adventures the monsters are
taking a much-needed break from the
hotel and setting sail on an epic
vacation on a monster cruise ship miss
summer vacation ever but it's not all
smooth sailing in the film that also
stars Joe Jonas David Spade and Kathryn
Hahn who's got a dark secret that
threatens the monsters very existence
but don't hold that against me we don't
know right away is it Erica is actually
Erica van Helsing
so she's the part of the family that's
been hunting Dracula for generations
right for Chrissy it's a frightful good
time that she's planning on sharing with
little women I can't wait to be able to
bring her down that red carpet be able
to go see this movie I just cannot wait
[Music]